hey guys happy Friday I'm doing
something a little different today on
the daily Deni because as you know
Beyonce is gearing up to hit the road
again with hubby jay-z for the sequel to
their on the run tour which got us
thinking about some of Queen B's most
unforgettable tour moments let's be real
whether she's on the run or rolling solo
gone say never disappoints there was the
time B brought the fire and the water
performing during a lightning storm on a
formation tour stop and when her ear
literally started bleeding during her
Title X performance
[Music]
the show must go on even when mrs.
Carter snatches are all wig
[Applause]
[Music]
she didn't even miss a beat because
Beyonce always on beat and when she
sneezed the music superstar also loves
her fans but she also loves her chosen
family like dance captain Ashley Everett
Ashley's boyfriend choreographer John
Silver
popped the question during the st. Louis
show on the formation world tour in 2016
with the help of B of course when I
caught an accent I said I talked to the
choreographers and I say yo you have to
do with no sing ladies and I finally got
back to B and she was like have you guys
congratulations it was really genuine
and sweet the how's this for a surprise
[Applause]
Serena Williams surprised the crowd on
B's final stop on the formation tour for
a fierce recreation of her cameo and
sorry but it's her husband jay-z who has
made a habit of surprising a Beyonce
crowd the most during her shows so when
the couple embarked on their first joint
tour in 2015 well it was magic Beyonce
and jay-z are set to recreate that magic
when they're on the run to tour kicks
off on June 6 in the UK before coming
stateside on July 25th okay it is Friday
and you know I wouldn't stray you
without sharing some new music
kick it off my pics this week is Shawn
Mendes that's right Adam rip on celeb
crush dropped his latest single in my
blood and there's a reason fans are so
emotional about it
[Music]
in my blood is the lead single off his
upcoming third album and the song which
is about his anxiety is apparently the
first thing he wrote during his studio
session anyways I thought you guys might
like that and sticking with the guitar
theme Keith Urban teamed up with Julia
Michaels for this beautiful yet
surprisingly swaggy collab coming home
punjah never let you go there's nothing
in the world
[Music]
and finally here's a turn up track for
you David Guetta and SIA reunite for the
fourth time with another banger and this
one is called flames
[Music]
I think I need to see on every song okay
all right well those are my new music
Friday picks for you guys I'm actually
headed to Keith Urban's hood aka
Nashville Tennessee so I won't be here
on Monday but don't worry we have a new
daily Denny with a special guest host to
make sure you guys come back on Monday
and I'll see you next week I'm on vaycay
peace